-Our next guests
are the writers and producers
behind the movie "Dumb Money,"
which is playing
in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Hey, do you -- do you remember
back at Stonehill
when they dared me
to run that mile naked?
-Yeah, there was a crazy storm
that night.
-Everybody remembers that.
-Okay.
-They do, man.
You don't think people remember
your four-minute,
three-second mile?
-Oh, what is this, a pep talk?
-Stop hiding.
Seriously, okay?
Stop being all meek and [bleep]
and running away.
-What, you want me to run
through lightning
with my [bleep] out?
-Yeah.
Please. Exactly that.
Run through lightning
with your [bleep] out.
[Bleep] it.
-Please welcome to the show
Lauren Schuker Blum
and Rebecca Angelo, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome! I'm so happy
to have you both here.
-We're happy to be here.
-And, you know, we don't often
have two guests at once,
but you are the best
coordinated outfits
I've ever seen on the show.
-We tried.
-You tried very hard,
and it paid off big time.
-She's in charge of outfits.
I just listen.
-Yeah.
-So, I think
the GameStop phenomenon
was something
we were all aware of,
but maybe didn't fully
understand the details of.
For those who weren't fully
up to speed on it,
can you just explain what
happened in that moment at time?
-Yeah, it's David and Goliath.
It is the insane, true story
of thousands of regular people
who came together and beat
Wall Street at its own game.
-And they were led
by this guy Keith Gill,
who went by the name
Roaring Kitty
and Deep [bleep] Value online.
He had two names.
And he is...you know,
he's funny, he's weird.
He did his YouTube videos in cat
T-shirts with a red headband.
And he made fifty --
almost $50 million overnight
from GameStop, that
video game store at the mall
that we went to
as nerdy eight-year-olds.
-So, the thing about GameStop is
hedge funds
had shorted the company,
which meant that
if the business failed
and everybody who worked there
lost their jobs,
the hedge fund guys
would get rich.
But Keith and thousands
or even millions of other people
bought into the stock,
which sent the price soaring.
A bunch of them
got rich in the process,
and a few hedge funds
went under.
-And dumb money,
I did not realize,
is an actual term
that Wall Street uses
about the kind of investor
that Keith was.
-Right. Well, Wall Street
calls itself smart money.
Real, you know, original.
And they call retail investors
dumb money.
-So, in the moment
where the dumb money
was buying up GameStop,
they did not take it
seriously at first,
because they thought this just
proved their actual thesis,
which is that if we're on
the right side of this deal,
that has to be...
-Exactly.
The whole story
caught everyone by surprise.
-Yeah, they call it --
they call it a herding event.
So, like, literally they view
regular people as cattle.
So, did not take it seriously
until it was way too late.
-You guys met writing
for the Wall Street Journal.
And how, when you write
a screenplay like this,
how does your background
as reporters help
in, you know,
putting this story together?
-It's so helpful. I think
we're still reporters at heart,
and we interviewed
so many people on Wall Street,
we talked to retail traders,
and pretty much everything
in the movie is true,
except for one thing.
Pete Davidson,
who stars in the film,
plays a real guy
named Kevin Gill,
and Kevin is a DoorDasher.
He's an excellent DoorDasher
with a --
-The real Kevin is an excellent
DoorDasher.
He has a 99% rating.
-Okay.
-But when we cast
Pete Davidson,
we realized we can't sell
Pete Davidson
as an excellent DoorDasher.
[ Laughter ]
So we made him a DoorDasher
from hell in the movie.
-Gotcha.
-He eats people's food,
he drinks their drinks.
He's driving his car
all over their lawns.
-Now, you guys have been
up against something
that a lot of films
have been up about.
You have this incredible cast --
Paul Dano, Nick Offerman,
Seth Rogen...
-Sebastian Stan.
-America Ferrera.
-It's a great cast,
but unfortunately,
no one is able to go out
because of the SAG strike
and do press.
Which means that
as writers and producers,
you have been doing a great deal
of press for this movie.
Has that been
a strange experience?
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah. I wouldn't say...
We're, like, not supposed to be
brought into direct sunlight.
We're supposed to be
kept in, like, a closet.
-Yeah, writers are, like, behind
their laptops, hunched over.
And here we are
on national television.
You know, we were at
the Toronto Film Festival.
We pulled up to the red carpet
in our car
and we could hear
the crowd going crazy.
They were like,
"Yes, it's Seth Rogen!"
And then the doors open,
and the crowd was like, "Oh."
They got us.
-You did take a lovely photo
on the red carpet.
Like, don't
sell yourself short.
-We're trying so hard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Those bags, our friend
who designs Edie Parker
made those for us.
And they say "dumb" on one side
and "money" on the other.
And we got out of our car
so confidently
and held up our bags and
were smiling for the cameras.
And then somebody ran up to us
and switched around Lauren's bag
because she was flashing "dumb."
So, we were like idiots,
just like smiling
for the camera,
And it just said, "Dumb dumb."
-You're like, "We're famous!
Dumb dumb!"
-Yes.
-Your husband, Jason Blum,
who's a film producer,
he was actually here last week.
-He was.
-And he was talking
about the fact
that he had a movie
coming out,
and then he had
to change the date
because Taylor Swift
had a movie coming out.
He didn't want to open
the same weekend as her.
-Right.
-But then the issue was
that he might have
to move to the weekend
your movie was coming out,
and he said that was very tense.
-Yeah. Jerk.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he stole our weekend.
[ Laughter ]
-So, ultimately,
did it all work out okay?
-Things are going okay, yes.
But he had a competing project
to ours, also.
-Yeah.
-His own...
-Oh, he had his own...
-He had his own GameStop movie.
So we had a kind of, like,
Cold War in our house.
And every time the studio
called with notes,
I had to, like, hide
in the closet to take the notes.
And then I would open
the door afterwards
and I would hit Jason
in the face
'cause he was waiting outside,
eavesdropping.
-How could he do that
to his own wife?
-And our children were like
spies somehow, you know.
It was a tough 18 months.
-Alright.
I'm glad that you came out
the winner
on the GameStop saga.
-The important thing is we won.
-Yes, you did win.
And it's really
a wonderful movie,
and I hope that people
go out and see it.
I enjoyed it a great deal,
and it's so lovely
to have you both here.
Thank you so much.
You guys,
that's Lauren Schuker Blum
and Rebecca Angelo, everybody.
"Dumb Money"
is in theaters now.
Be right back
with more "Late Night."